When you play a video game, you're
automatically given access to the basic
content that makes that game what it is.
And if you want more missions,
more quests or character customizations,
then adding downloadable
content is usually an option.
But if that's not enough, maybe there's
an expansion pack that will give you
the gaming experience you desire.
And why am I telling you this?
Well, in this lesson,
you're going to learn about Ruby Core,
Ruby Standard Library, and RubyGems.
The core API is like
the original video game content.
The standard library is
like downloadable content.
And gems are like expansion packs.
RubyGems are my absolutely
favorite topic in all of Ruby,
because they open up a whole new world
of possibilities in our applications.
There are RubyGems for
pretty much everything.
Sending emails,
drawing ASCII art, creating web servers,
even telling knock knock jokes.
And by the end of this lesson,
you'll see how to find and
use RubyGems to improve
functionality in your own code.
All right, let's get started.